[Music]
okay
[Music]
greetings cinephiles i'm mark ellis and
welcome to rt essentials today we're
showcasing some of the greatest martial
arts fights from some of the greatest
martial arts actors ever these legends
deserve the utmost respect and you know
who i'm talking about the jackie chans
the bruce lee's the donnie yens the ones
who've done almost 100 of their own
stunts dedicating and risking their
lives for the love of the crap and not
in vain because the martial arts
subgenre is adored by millions and the
fights on this list have pushed the
cinematic boundaries while raising the
bar for all action films that followed
but mark how do we know which fights are
the best would you just relax this is
why i'm here these are the most iconic
martial arts fight scenes
it man versus 10 black belts ip man
first up is ip man versus 10 black belts
from the 2008 biographical actioner ip
man throughout the film it tries to keep
a low profile but he is enraged after
witnessing his friend master liu being
shot in the head by a deputy of general
miura it deduces that meera's also
killed his close friend lin so he
demands a match against 10 karateka at
once and brutally defeats every last one
of them for those unfamiliar with the
real ip man he was the grand master of
wing chun a southern chinese kung fu
style that blended quick arm and leg
movements with methods of relaxation and
softness madonko thinking softness is
harmless as it man stated in an
interview if one equates the soft skull
of marshall with weakness then they are
dead wrong wing chun is to maintain
one's flexibility and softness all the
while keeping in the strength to fight
back much like the flexible nature of
bamboo
that's so much wisdom i even mentioned
that he's the guy who trained
bruce lee so a total badass
and a movie loosely based on the life of
a badass requires badass actors in the
league enter chinese action star donnie
yen skilled in an array of martial arts
like tai chi taekwondo and yes most
relevantly wing chun yen spent months
training to prepare for this role when
he's described as the most emotionally
and mentally difficult in his career but
it paid off because it man was a
critical and commercial success and
spawned a four film series grandmaster
man would have been proud
fae hung vs jon drunken master 2.
jackie chan is one of the all-time
greats and we could spend entire
episodes just discussing some of his
classic fights and stunts and maybe
we'll get to do that eventually but for
today we're focusing on one particularly
iconic battle fae hung versus jon from
the action comedy drunken master 2. jan
plays wang fei hung a legendary chinese
martial artist who can't seem to stay
out of trouble and yes as the movie's
title suggests he's got a bit of a
drinking problem okay so he's got a
serious drinking problem which leads him
to consistently get into fights and
almost causing his father to lose his
land
you'd think that the constant drama
would be enough to motivate faehun to
lay off the sauce but it ain't so simple
the only way faehung is able to unlock
the drunken boxing fighting style and
reach peak martial arts performance is
to be intoxicated
god
[Music]
though the film takes the idea of
drunken boxing quite literally there's
actually a style of chinese martial arts
that imitates the movements of a drunk
person one that leans heavily on
deception and strange striking angles
this technique is utilized by chan as he
fights real-life taekwondo champion ken
lo in this beautifully choreographed
expertly shot sequence both chan and low
are performing all their own stunts
i don't know what's more impressive
lowe's kicking abilities are chance
tolerance for pain that shot where john
kicks fae hung onto a pile of burning
red hot coals and then fei hung shuffles
and crawls across them yeah it looks
realistic doesn't it because it's real
chad actually crawled over hot coals and
did it twice because he didn't feel like
he nailed it on the first take the guys
has a burning desire for perfection
neo vs morpheus the matrix
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if only learning kung fu was as simple
as hitting a download button like in the
neo vs morpheus fight from the matrix
when the wachowskis were conceptualizing
their action scenes they took direct
inspiration from several martial arts
films such as iron monkey once upon a
time in china and even drunken master
but the film that had the most obvious
influence was fist of legend a 1994 hong
kong actioner produced by and starring
jet li
fist of legend was a remake of the 1972
bruce lee film pistol fury we'll get to
that later if you're looking for clues
as to why the fighting in the matrix so
closely resembles the fighting in fist
of legend look no further than hong kong
martial arts choreographer yen woo ping
who the wachowskis were huge fans of and
imported to hollywood to work on their
films wu peng had only four months to
train and prep the matrix actors so they
could perform most of their own stunts
according to wu ping martial arts takes
a lifetime to master so they were in
quite a hurry adding that everyone had
injuries from the intensive process and
that it was all created with blood sweat
and tears
[Music]
come on stop trying to hit me and hit me
as they say no pain no gain and all that
work resulted in one of the most
groundbreaking fight scenes in cinematic
history in which a sparring program set
in a traditional east asian dojo is
constructed so that neo can practice his
hand-to-hand combat on morpheus this
sequence employs the tactics of wire foo
which is common in hong kong cinema and
combines kung fu with wire work hence
the name it's a beautifully shot tribute
to the films that inspired the
wachowskis and a testament to keanu
reeves lawrence fishburne and wu ping's
dedication to their work
rama vs machete gang the raid redemption
in the indonesian action thriller the
raid redemption one fight stands above
the rest and it's rama versus the
machete gang fighting one person holding
a machete is tricky enough i definitely
don't recommend it fighting an entire
gang of machete-wielding martial arts
experts uh that's just plain nuts but
protagonist rama played by eko eways
doesn't have much of a choice because in
the raid he's on a mission to take down
a brutal crime ward named tama thomas
offered sanctuary to every criminal in
his high-rise apartment block and now
rama must lead a team of commandos on a
violent charge through the building for
such a seemingly chaotic sequence a
tremendous amount of careful planning
was required specifically when it came
to fight choreography
rama rapidly dodges blade swing after
blade swing and delivers one of the most
disturbingly awesome kills you might
ever see in a film in which he jumps in
the air holding a gang member's head
and slams said gang member's head down
onto the sharp remnants of a broken door
like i said disturbing but exactly the
kind of thing you sign up to see in a
movie called the raid redemption actor
iko ooways was working as an operational
driver at an indonesian telecom company
when he caught the attention of raid
director gareth evans in a training hall
one thing led to another and ooway soon
had his first leading role in evans
martial arts film marantao and which
then led him to sign a five-year
contract with evans production company
eventually ues was able to resign from
his driver job so that he could focus on
you know beating up bad guys full time
dojo fight vista fury
hey
uh
it doesn't get more iconic than the dojo
fight scene from the 1972 film fist of
fury starring bruce lee
lee plays chen zhen a kung fu fighter
who's hell-bent on avenging his
relatives and bringing justice to those
who are responsible for his master's
death this leads to some serious butt
kicking at the dojo when zen challenges
not one fighter but all fighters at once
there's so much to unpack in this scene
from the superb one-liners like you must
be tired of living to the epic mullet
some of these guys are rocking uh by the
way again this was 1972 a decade ahead
of the mullet craze and those adr sound
effects which may sound out of place
today they did contribute to the overall
style and charm of the film but the real
reason this scene lands on our list is
lee himself who is so incredibly
magnetic so hilarious at times and yet
always powerful he commands the
attention of the audience with his skill
and personality alone you can't look
away
he's also in really good shape and he
takes the shirt off and uh those abs
aren't free trust me
but still nobody's ever been or will
ever be like bruce lee again and this
film especially this fight sequence are
part of what defined his career and made
him the legend that we still admire
today speaking of legends here's a fun
fact a very young jackie chan appeared
in this film as both a student and a
stunt double and at one point actually
gets kicked by lee and flies through the
air
ugh getting kicked by bruce lee
kind of an honor
bone breaker fight the protector
[Music]
[Music]
the bone breaker foot from the 2005 thai
film the protector holds the guinness
world record for the most bones broken
in a single scene okay i might have made
that part up but you can believe it's
true the protector originally titled tom
young goong follows a young fighter
named com who travels to australia in
search of the stolen elephants that were
originally promised to the king of
thailand multi-talented actor tony jobs
stars in the leading role one in which
his fighting prowess is on full display
jaw grew up watching the films of bruce
lee jackie chan and jet li and was
inspired to follow in the footsteps of
his idols he began his muay thai
training at the age of 10 and by the age
of 15 he was a protege of thai director
and stuntman hannah ritikrett
what
[Music]
job finally had his breakout leading
role in the 2003 film ongbok muay thai
warrior directed by pratya pinkau pinkau
would go on to direct this film shah's
second major movie and gift us with this
sequence in which jaw literally breaks
people's arms and legs for four minutes
straight for this film jock created a
new style of muay thai which translates
to elephant boxing and in an interview
stated that he wanted the moves to
imitate how an elephant would defend
itself with the arms acting as the trunk
jackie chan called jaw the most
well-rounded of all action stars and i
think jackie's right you can't find me
another actor that can gang-fight while
imitating an elephant
my june versus tony flashpoint
[Music]
donnie yen is back in the mahjoon vs
tony fight scene from the film
flashpoint mahjoon a police officer with
a reputation for violent behavior
manages to track down tony a brutal
criminal towards the end of the film and
the two face off in an abandoned village
it's a grueling display of hand-to-hand
combat no weapons no elephant
impressions just fisticuffs okay there
is some kicking too it is martial arts
after all similar to many of the actors
on this list yen isn't just the star of
his films he is also heavily involved in
the fight choreography and performs his
own stunts for the fights in flashpoint
yen combined elements of jujitsu karate
boxing judo taekwondo and washu if
you're keeping score at home i know none
of those
[Music]
[Music]
he also wanted to ensure that the action
scenes hit as hard as they possibly
could literally so he insisted that
taiwanese martial artist cohen xiao be
cast as tony xiao is known for his role
in the first two matrix sequels and i
start alongside jet li and jackie chan
and that's exactly why this fight scene
is so effective you have two experts at
the peak of their powers doing what they
do best being badasses if you're
wondering who wins the fight
go watch flashpoint it's awesome
shoe glen versus jen u crouching tiger
hidden dragon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next up is shu lin vs jen yu from the
hit film crouching tiger hidden dragon
directed by ang lee this is easily one
of the most epic sword duels i've ever
seen well at least on film i haven't
seen that many sword duels in person
though there are two states in the u.s
washington and texas where you can
legally challenge someone to a duel so
long as the police officer oversees it
probably shouldn't get involved in that
i digress
sheelan is played by michelle yo a role
which earned her a baptist nomination
for best actress and contributed to her
reputation as one of the greatest action
heroines of all time not to be outshined
by her co-star zhang ziyi who plays jan
yu and has become one of the most
awarded and recognized chinese actresses
in history the level of talent between
the two of them is almost too much for
one scene and once you add in wu ping
yen's choreography into the mix it's a
done deal this fight is a masterpiece
and if you disagree you can meet me in
texas or washington and we'll settle
this
[Music]
yo admitted in interviews that she was
unfamiliar with the traditional styles
director angley had in mind blending
influences from peking opera and
acrobatics and during a pivotal sequence
in the film yo tore a knee ligament
while performing one of her own stunts
but like the badass she is she returned
to work as soon as she healed from the
surgery and finished her remaining
scenes joe's real-life pain and
dedication mirrored her characters and
in one of yo's tearful goodbye sequences
leigh had to excuse himself to cry in
private for 15 minutes after being so
moved by her performance saying that he
knew those tears were real
rama vs the assassin the raid 2 barondo
strikes again in the rama versus the
assassin fight from the raid 2 barondo
in this sequel to the raid redemption
ram has attracted the attention of
gangsters even more deadly than the last
and with his family now at risk he must
lay his life on the line once again to
finally destroy the criminal empire
after infiltrating a warehouse and
battling a plethora of henchmen then
fighting a girl who uses claw hammers as
her signature weapon and also fighting
her brother a guy winning a baseball bat
rama comes upon the top enforcer in the
film known as the assassin in a kitchen
and the two duke it out you'd think rama
would have had it up by this point but
this is eco always we're talking about
remember the guy who wiped the floor
with an entire gang of dudes with
machetes
oh
anyways as reality tv has taught us if
there's too many cooks in the kitchen
one of them's gotta go and what ensues
is over six minutes of unrelentingly
vicious combat featuring ooace's go-to
pen jack salat style
this indonesian form of martial arts
involves full body fighting with rapid
striking grappling and occasionally
tossing in some weaponry like the sharp
karen bits that assassin whips out
mid-fight according to director gareth
evans this kitchen fight took a month
and a half to design due to the
complexity and intricate choreography
like all the fight sequences in the raid
films the crew practiced on crash mats
in a rented out office space rehearsing
and shooting the scene until it was just
right before they then tackled a real
shot on location
thomas vs thug wheels on meals
[Music]
last up is thomas vs thug from the samo
hung action comedy wheels on meals for
this scene chan is fighting benny
orkidez an american kickboxing champion
who is nicknamed the jet due to his
explosive spinning back kick and in
several of his movies he portrays a
tough and almost undefeatable bad guy
that kind you wait until the climax of
the film to fight and that's exactly
what happens in wheels on meals
[Music]
this chan vs fight is considered one of
the greatest in any film ever and even
chan himself was blown away by the skill
and power of her kids but not as blown
away as that row of candles that are
kidas extinguishes with the airflow from
one of his spin kicks yeah that wasn't
movie magic he actually did that and
there you have it our selections for the
most iconic martial arts fights
obviously we could include every epic
sequence that fits the criteria but fear
not there are plenty of new episodes of
rt essentials coming your way so i'm
sure we'll get to hard target eventually
thanks again for tuning in i'm mark
ellis and to all you is finally martial
arts filmmakers out there remember what
bruce lee said absorb what is useful
discard what is useless and add what is
specifically your own
[Applause]
[Music]
you